ce matin est ce que vous avez ordonné la
poursuite de la grève aux vôtres tout
d'abord je redonne rien du tout c'est
les salariés qui décident bien sûr aux
tiers bien sûr fier de faire cette grève
c'est énormément de courage la
contestation jambières merci elle est
utile mais les cris les invectives les
menaces les coûts le sont beaucoup moins
voyez là moi je vous ai répondu et puis
vous avez le dernier mot non je veux
juin je dis ça c'est pas passé comme ça
ça s'est pas passé comme ça l'avis de
grève qui commande c'est qu'on trouve la
solution on retrouve le chemin ensemble
a fait le seabel si les français me
choisit le drop est bien sûr d'abord
faire dans la tête
ford nous les a toujours pour moi pour
sermonner plus intelligent que par stu
ne veut rien dire non plus et venez pas
des gens de citéa première mort si vous
pouvez aller me consulter nos casiers
judiciaires train alors c'est parti de
l'intimidation ça fait pas peur ça
énerve les accusations de la direction
vous avez été reconnue en train de
lancer un oeuf à bout portant
sous la violence du choc il a chuté au
sol
merci monsieur le président
on sera toujours très josie lévy le cas
sera jamais rien on sera toujours très
anti âge assure pouvoir y aura des
surprises car il
ouais
ça commence à flipper les cabinets de
hollande
non
je
je vais je suis dans le serveur
c'est vrai en plus la souris et rats